hello there reject nation what is your
name
juliet follow her
on instagram that's all she asks to be
here today
she needs it bleeding for followers it's
really rough these days for her
totally hasn't grown at all
i'm so sorry for the failures in your
life
yes this is awful life you had like oh
my goodness thank you so much for your
sympathy
i know i just it's been a hard i'm woke
i sound
like an egomaniac now no you guys power
there
you'll enjoy it never know how to
properly promote
someone's instagram anywho i asked julia
to be here today and one of the things
we're going to cover today is a try not
to laugh
challenge that's right she's never done
one this is for family guy
you're not that familiar not super i've
seen bits and pieces
okay so this should be a challenge
indeed because we're going to do a
really hard one that might get
demonetized because of the title
peaches and cream dirty jokes
compilation no
best of luck juliet thank you if you
smile you smile and if you laugh that's
okay just restart okay
none of this like do i keep going don't
take your headphones i hate when people
do that to me
all right do people do that what do i do
now
and then they leave i'm like we're still
recording
one two three
i'm so sorry by the way you call those
cheap implants boobs
those are boobs they're lying you've
never even had a boyfriend more than a
few weeks
i have too
[Music]
lois you under your mind we can't let
quagmire take meg out on a date that guy
will bang anything
hey lois i'm stabbing what's for dinner
i'm in meatloaf it's in the fridge
hey peter do you mind but i have to get
dinner go out
you know mortgage yeah still finding out
new stuff about you
that's the adventure there's a nerd in
there maybe there
is
intercourse over 200 reports of ear sex
have been confirmed so
far prompting a new slogan once you go
black you go deaf
i'm doing story time with stewie yes
grab drinky
i got a story it's about the little
penis that couldn't
it dicks it can
[Music]
all right let's make sure we don't cover
up this all right
it's what puts candy in the bag oh look
chris here's your costume from the year
you won as a condom
yeah who are you supposed to be dance
for these virtual reality glasses so i
can watch porn while talking to the
family
so what's california like stewie yeah
that was your penis so do you still
want to know about california no i'm
done fruit baskets covered in celery
how may i help you long juicy bananas
and melon balls
now i know you hadn't asked me a
question i was just thinking about
another part of my day
ew dad we don't want to sit here and
look at your ass
yes i'd rather look at meg toweling off
after a shower when she does that
butt floss thing you you that's so
disgusting uh i hope i don't ever
accidentally use that towel
hmm carney d'amico the name sounds
familiar
i better go check meg's yearbook pages 4
6
11 27 41 42 and 60 to see if it's the
babe i'm thick enough lois i'll take my
dessert upstairs in the masturbation
bathroom
hey man you gotta have one of those
right no i'm looking for chris
i've looked everywhere and i can't find
him huh i haven't seen him but i'll keep
an eye out
hey
what do they represent oh wow that's a
really good
question
it's just her thinking face
i can't tell you explicitly since we're
owned by disney but
let me just say that santa made her
little mermaid
moana oh exactly
brian would you hand me the fat man's
fancy puking hat
that sounds hard oh i will find a
swearer
dad why are we sitting on the washing
machine because in canada
men have vaginas well we had another
good quarter
i guess a lot of people are sneezing out
there jerry i'm going to let you in on
saturday
and can't leave this room our research
shows the primary use of our product is
sperm
what yeah and breaks yourself for this
the second biggest use is women crying
about nonsense
but i thought sneezing hurt jerry it's
sperm and
nonsense even crisps grow together like
peaches and cream
peaches peaches i'm sorry damn it you
could have at least given me some
warning at least
a shoulder tap i know oh i just got it
you're so beautiful i can't control
myself
i can't stay mad at you how about a kiss
no no i guess you're right
there's no way we can afford it plus if
i go that means i won't be here to help
out around the house or feed you guys or
monitor your internet usage every day
you should go
because they want to masturbate
looks like someone was up late yeah i
tend to sleep a little longer when i'm
resting under a big
furry bear
[Music]
it's okay you're part of it now
go with it ugh corbell
it's not called bear let's go with it
yes i had some left over from denise's
wedding mr elise
go with it fine how is denise did she
have the abortion abortion
go with it no her alarm didn't go off so
she missed it
so ryan is this your first orgy not
going
you're looking well and this is anton
he's in the touring company of dear evan
hansen
bye we're all very modern he's just here
because i got gum
on him and he's stuck in my hand
okay that's sick
some of these are so weird without
context
they're
all right look just put him down and use
your fists
no no no no here it is washington dc
the seat of government for the world's
former most powerful nation
wow those are all the monuments i read
about in school there's the washington
monument
there's the obama monument
i panicked it's okay don't worry chris
you can't always get things right on the
first try
just look at snoopy's original oh my god
[Applause]
oh no oh no oh no two newcomers this
year
pepe the ultra frog and hops the dog the
beloved beer pitman
in fact hops is so popular that hundreds
of quahog women have volunteered to blow
up his balloon
[Music]
most of you did well some of you i think
can do better
what do you see here chris
two days and a half dad where did you
get this car i bought it from quagmire
he's not home because he got abducted by
aliens last night
so do you guys just not do the anal
probe anymore is that no that's
more or less been retired i see
you do you still have the thing i've
been trying to get back on television
ever since i stopped hosting family feud
how are you betsy welcome to the show
you are a lovely young woman
you know i just get my hand up there and
feel that one
and that one and we're looking for
something you shop for at the mall
three seconds yes just look at our great
city bustling with activity
even the chimney sweeps are hard at work
it's all dirty in here
i don't care keep going shouldn't i wear
some sort of protective suit
why don't you trust me i do but our
friend bartholomew went in lots of
chimneys in the 80s and now he's sick
oh look you can go to oral roberts
oh and there's anal roberts boy that is
a tough
tough place to get into lois that is
tough but once you're in there you'll be
surprised how much you like it
step right up everybody take a chance
just shut up peter i'm done with you all
right you completely lied about why you
were hungry
what i never lied well check that out
one time
oh my god my husband's having a heart
attack is anyone here a doctor
i have a 13 inch penis
joe i just wish we could do more but
obviously your mouth is full
and you probably don't want any
reminders of bonnie around the house so
i cleared out all of her underwear
okay don't be a stranger yeah because
we're not supposed to talk to those
oh i think it's over
[Laughter]
i realized for some of it i was here
and i forgot that you put the screen in
the middle
don't you i was like this this is all
staying damn it
in the video now
and they're dawn on me like
i might have ruined it no you're good
you're good you're still in frame
i know but like then you put in the
middle i'll figure it out okay so i have
to hop around
you know what the worst is is when
someone's like wow
then i'm like great i'm gonna have this
weird shifting picture on the band
isn't it nice to catch up with me after
so long yeah
hey juliet i don't know if you know the
things i'm forced to watch
like come over here let's
like hit me halfway through like what a
weird scenario here
that i just put this person through
oh man you know what's been on the
channel come on bye
and i haven't seen any of that i don't
i'm not a regular viewer
a family guy but some of it was pretty i
was that i was surprised
someone who watches family guy regularly
i was still surprised by some of the
jokes that are here like they'll go for
like the
the hardcore edgy jokes constantly but
there are some things that they got away
with that i was like damn
i've never seen that episode and i can't
believe they got away with saying that i
didn't even know what to expect
so it would seem like it was getting you
a few amount of time
there were some there's some pretty good
ones in there i don't remember what i
mean that obama one was
oh my god that was one of the best ones
that's probably my favorite one of them
definitely one of the best
that's when you could only do an
animation to really pull it off you know
like that was so clever
that was pretty good oh well overall i
think you did a
good job for your first try not to laugh
challenge you didn't annoyingly feel
like you have to start over
i feel like you lost kind of early i'll
play it back i did i did
i think the uh the fake blue one got me
right away
wow right in the beginning i i'm sorry
to bring you over here to watch this
video right now
okay it's all right well i'll come over
here and watch a dirty video
this is exactly what he texted me yeah
okay sure why not
[Laughter]
i'm sorry it's okay i'm still
enjoyable well guys follow juliet on
instagram today
do yourself a favor
to the real rejects click that
notification bell last but not least
let's do a pic
and speaking of trying not to laugh
challenges our good buddy
jean jeter has put together another one
of his wacky hilarious try not to laughs
of tyra magnus
and scarlow it's bizarre as you'd expect
it to be
scarlow broke on two of them i'm waiting
to see if she'll break on a third one
i'd encourage you guys to go
hit up tyrone magnus and make sure he
does i try not to laugh to one of these
because let's face it when it comes to
trying to laughs
he's one of the kings of them i really
think he would have a [ __ ] in time
with this one so yeah guys there's a
link in the description box
it's fun it's hard it's bizarre it'll be
unlike anything you watch on youtube
this week
give it a shot i highly recommend it
thanks jean jeter merry christmas to you
too buddy
[Music]
you